[Music]
one of my big questions was do people in
positions of power want to give back
and I've been shocked that a hundred
percent of the people I've talked to
have wanted to send the elevator back
down they all remember when they you
know were at the bottom and needed
someone to take a shot on them needed
their break and everyone wants to kind
of relive that moment vicariously
through helping other people
Protege is a website where you can get
in touch with the biggest experts in the
world so for example if you're trying to
make it in music you could send a demo
of your music to scooter bronze send
your Beats to DJ Khaled you get
opportunity to get feedback and
potentially get discovered so think of
it kind of like modern day American Idol
meets masterclass
[Music]
I grew up my whole life actually wanting
to be a musician didn't have connections
grew up in Houston immigrant family
didn't know a soul in the music industry
and no matter how much effort I put into
it I just couldn't get anyone to take a
meeting to listen to any of my demos
so I realized you know later on that so
much of success is based on who you know
and unfortunately not everyone has you
know family connections or comes from
the right background so something we're
really trying to fix is democratizing
access to opportunity
foreign
[Music]
a half million from over 50 celebrity
investors and Sequoia which you know was
a venture firm that I really wanted to
work with my whole career and it's tough
right we we had even before we raised
our first Venture round one of our
strategies was well to get these experts
really invested not just you know doing
it transactionally let's get as many of
them as possible on our cap table so we
created an SPV and I got over 150 Angel
Investors on before we got a single
Venture Capital fund we had everyone
investing from Lupe Fiasco DJ Khaled
Will Smith Lionel Richie DJ Khaled was a
really interesting one you know our team
asked him like
how much would you charge for an hour of
your time he's like an hour with like
lights and makeup and flying like that's
like five hours no like an actual hour
of your time how much would you charge
he's like I don't know like 10 grand
which sounds like a lot so I did some
quick math and I said well 10 grand
divided by 60 minutes it's only 160
dollars per minute can I pay you 160 to
watch and give feedback to to this kid
who really wants to hear what you think
about his music he's like wait so you're
telling me instead of scrolling on tick
tock on my phone I can give feedback to
people and make equivalent of 10 grand
an hour just watching videos like I
would on Snapchat and Tick Tock so it
was really compelling for him from both
a kind of financial as well as a you
know philanthropic standpoint
foreign
[Music]
we've had over 50 000 people create
accounts sign up for the app these are
people not just in music but people who
are trying to make it and acting people
try to make it an arts film this has
been my life dream my my first stream
was I wanted to make it in music and now
I've kind of come full circle and we're
helping other people accomplish their
dreams I would love my legacy to be that
I helped democratize access that we
helped create more opportunity through
Protege that my co-founder Mike and I
were able to change the world and and
make it a more accessible place
foreign